BRIT CRUISE: When we
perform calculations
with a pen and
paper, we often need
to save intermediate results.
And we may do this
with, say, scrap paper.
And in this case,
the paper is acting
as a form of external memory.
And memory, no matter the
form, takes up physical space.
Computers contain memory.
We can think of it as the
scrap paper for the computer.
And say, when you
construct an array
to store values in your
program, you require memory.
And at the lowest
level, computers
read and store all instructions
as a string of numbers.
But how do you store
numbers in a machine?
This was a very difficult
problem originally.
Especially when you need
computers to hold their memory
after the access
to power is lost.
This is known as
non-volatile memory.
The easiest difference
for a machine to detect
is simply a presence versus
an absence of something.
And this is how old
punch cards would work.
Along the top, we
have some data.
And the vertical
columns contain a series
of punched holes, which
represent each character.
So computers really have
two fingers, base two.
The same as a light switch being
on for one and off for zero.
This is the smallest
amount of information,
a single difference,
which we call a bit.
But bits are
powerful for storage
because the amount
of unique states
grows exponentially as
we add bits together.
Remember one light
switch is one bit
and it can store two states.
But two light switches can
store four unique states.
And eight light
switches, or 8 bits,
can store 256 unique states.
And space is measured in bits.
But the physical
size of a bit depends
on your method of storage.
So how do computer store
zeroes and ones internally?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: Modern data
processing systems
like these use thousands
of magnetic cores.
What are magnetic cores?
They are tiny rings
of nickel alloy
or other magnetic materials.
They have replaced vacuum tubes
for many important functions
in data processing systems.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIT CRUISE: And it allowed
computers to store bits
as clockwise versus
counterclockwise magnetization
direction.
Because each core
could be magnetized
in two different ways,
depending which direction
the current was applied.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: Because a
bit can be represented
by any bi-stable device.
And the magnetic core
is a bi-stable device.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIT CRUISE: Later
on, this was done
using thin film
magnetic disk, where
we can think of as each a bit
as a tiny magnetic cell, which
can be charged to store
either a 1 or a 0.
So long story short,
the size of a bit
has been rapidly shrinking
since the days of punch cards.
A hard drive in
a modern computer
can be thought of as billions
of tiny magnetic cells.
Now you may wonder,
well, how small
can these little
magnetic cells be?
And current research
at IBM is pushing this
to the atomic level.
Where they have
shown 12 iron atoms
can work together as a
stable magnetic unit.
Where they're able
to store a 1 or a 0,
depending on how
they're oriented.
And this is approaching
a theoretical limit
where we would hold a
single bit on a single atom.
And interestingly
IBM estimates that we
could put around one
quadrillion bits of information
in a handheld device the size
of an iPod with atomic storage.
And let's call
this a super drive.
It doesn't even exist yet.
As a hypothetical example,
a small handheld super drive
using atomic storage
would hold 1,000 terabits,
which is 1,000
trillion switches.
Or more commonly
known as 125 terabytes
in the palm of your hand.
Or to use an example
everyone can understand,
125 terabytes is the same as
having a 1,250-kilometer-long
bookshelf in the
palm of your hand.
And this is what the future
of memory looks like.
Will we ever be able to
store a bit on something
smaller than an atom?